je vous amène à la face cachée de che
parrot c'est à dire un grand un grand
problème ici en dans le sud de l'albanie
est un peu partout c'est qu'il ya pas de
bennes à ordures donc les gens y
laissent leur poubelle comme ça c'est
pas possible je dire les touristes c'est
ce qu'ils voient en premier le dire il
voit le jeu on peut pas c'est impossible
les déchets un fléau dans tout le pays
en pleine campagne aux abords des
rivières dans les décors majestueux des
montagnes sur les lacs
où en pleine ville parfois à quelques
mètres seulement des habitations partout
le même spectacle de décharge à ciel
ouvert
vingt ans après être sortie du
communisme le pays a plongé de plain
pied dans la société de consommation et
faute de moyens a bien du mal à gérer
ses déchets la venoge est l'un des
principaux militants pour la défense de
l'environnement
il nous a donné rendez-vous dans la
périphérie de tirana vous voyez ces gars
là regardez ce n'est pas une façon de
nettoyer on a de si beaux paysages sans
compter d'incroyables ressources en eau
ce qui est une vraie richesse pour ce
pays
mais quand vous voyez toutes ces ordures
qui se déverse dans la mer
tout cela affecte le tourisme sans
parler des problèmes de santé publique
et de l'image que cela donne du pays
c'est un vrai défi que de changer cette
situation
pour l'instant l'environnement ne semble
pas encore être la priorité des
autorités
hervé loiselet est tombé amoureux de la
région
on va arriver
chez parrot c'est un des plus beaux
villages du sud de l'albanie c'est un
nid d'aigle on va dire et
[Musique]
hervé est français depuis dix ans il
travaille comme décorateur à tirana il a
décidé d'investir dans le village de che
parrot il y a acheté une résidence
secondaire et vient d'aménager une
chambre d'hôtes les albanais
généralement ii ne devant pas aux
étrangers
il aime bien gardé
leur maison pour eux parce que c'est
vraiment c'est très important pour eux
donc moi j'ai une chance inouïe de
pouvoir acheter cette maison
village est quasiment abandonné il ya il
doit y avoir une vingtaine d'habitants
pas plus
j'ai du village
voilà et moi je suis celui-là ou encore
plus haut
là
la route ne va pas plus loin hervé doit
faire les derniers mètres à pied tout le
voisinage des sens pour l'aider à
transporter ses bagages et à ouvrir sa
maison il est le seul étranger de che
part au haut débit
l'accueil n'était pas si chaleureux
construisait je faisais les murs quand
je partais il cassait les murs donc avec
beaucoup de diplomatie
finalement je fais ça en deux ans donc
c'est énorme jalousie méfiance envers
les étrangers
aujourd'hui ils vivent en bonne harmonie
le plus important pour nous c'est que
bientôt des français des anglais des
allemands vont venir ici laisse que nous
sommes prêts à les accueillir et à
travailler
c'est une relation réciproque en
contrebas de sa ville a acheté pour 16
mille euros hervé a aménagé une petite
maison d'hôtes où il peut loger quatre
personnes il espère pouvoir la loue et
350 euros par semaine donc il ya deux
leviers qui font canapé c'est très
simple petite cuisine jardinage une
maison tout confort mais hervé doit
composer avec un réseau de distribution
d'eau défaillant il était le problème
c'est qu'il ya une demi-heure d'eau par
jour
mais j'ai trois mille litres d'eau de
réserve donc savage arriva j'arrive à
tourner avec l'eau sans problème il ne
compte pas s'arrêter en si bon chemin
il a déjà de nouveaux projets
d'investissement dans le village ça
c'est là c'est super c'est magnifique
hervé voudrait acheter cette maison pour
son jardin et surtout pour sa situation
exceptionnelle
[Musique]